this is what weeks of torrential rain
has done to towns Villages and farmland
on the banks of the Tanana River more
than
170,000 people have been forced from
their homes by floods here in Kenya many
had to swim or Wade to the safety of
Higher Ground where they're staying in
camps some didn't make it R delain and
her children are among those who
did the flood came to our home and we
had to cross the water to come here I
was able to save the children but our
chickens were washed away here we've had
to drink dirty water and the children
have diarrhea rukia's children aren't
alone this Baby's also had diarrhea
since arriving at the camp along with
his sister there's no clean water to
drink the Red Cross takes them to
hospital it says it'll Supply water at
the camps but it needs support looking
at what the weatherman has predicted
that we are about to experience the
speak of this and given that it's likely
to go over 6 months the humanitarian
needs are going to be huge that means
it's going to be large scale need for
humanitarian assistance meteorologists
had predicted the rains they're
connected to the El Nino a climate cycle
in the Pacific Ocean two months ago the
government said it put aside about $65
million to help people the deputy
president has since said there are no
funds available yeah it can be stolen
the corruption can coming you know when
it is not well
coordinated many of the flooded
communities are now only accessible by
air from the helicopter you can really
get a sense of the scale of these floods
and all along the banks of the Tana
River thousands of farms have been
submerged the crops destroyed and this
comes off the back of one of the worst
droughts in this region in about 40
years climate scientists say the cycle
of shocks is only expected to get
worse scientists say the climatic Trends
can only be stopped by a global
reduction in carbon emissions
governments are due to discuss it at the
un's climate change Conference next week
in
Dubai many people here can barely afford
fossil fuels but they pay the highest
price Malcolm web Al jazer Tanner River
County
Kenya make sure to subscribe to our
Channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer